hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing all of the Hidden
rooms unknown Chambers and secret
passageways within Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
Hogwarts Castle is known for the fact
that its location is well unknown
unpossible on a map and basically
invisible to Muggles the school and its
surrounding grounds have quite the
reputation for harboring many magical
Secrets this of course includes an
absolutely insane number of hidden areas
within the castle in today's video I'll
be taking you through all the ones that
we know about starting with secret
passageways doors and shortcuts let's
begin with all of the Hidden ways that
one can maneuver themselves in out and
around the castle and surrounding
grounds there are many number of secret
passageways hidden doors and shortcuts
students and professors alike not to
mention filch and his cat Mrs Norris
have been able to move undetected
through the hallowed Halls of Hogwarts
for centuries whether these hidden
passageways were built alongside the
foundation of the castle back in the
10th Century or later on I suppose we'll
never truly know what we do know is that
the majority of the following Secret
ways through Hogwarts still exist to
this day 1. the tunnel beneath the
one-eyed witch statue near the stairs
that take you to the defense against the
dark arts classroom there is a secret
tunnel that leads you to the cellar of
honeydukes a sweet shop in the
neighboring Wizarding Village of
hogsmeade one can only access the hidden
passageway by tapping the hump of the
one-eyed witch statue that stands there
and uttering the word descendium which
makes the witch's hump open up to reveal
the secret tunnel 2. the passage behind
a fourth floor mirror this passageway
was once accessible by locating a mirror
on the fourth floor of the castle it's
said that the tunnel which also led to
the Village of hogsmeade was apparently
large enough to hold a meeting in had
caved in on itself by the year 1992.
3. the passageway beneath the Whomping
Willow this passageway was rumored to
have been created for Remus Lupine who
was both a wizard and a werewolf when he
was a student at Hogwarts with the
intention that he would use it to
isolate himself each month when he
transformed the tunnel led to the
abandoned house in hogsmeade Village
known as the shrieking Shack to access
it one needed to press a specific knot
in the wood of the Whomping Willow's
trunk immobilizing its deadly branches
and allowing the traveler to access the
opening into the passageway
4. the tunnel behind the statue of
Gregory the smarmy a passageway hidden
behind a statue of Gregory this mommy
medieval British Wizard and potioneer
this tunnel was evidently not too
difficult to find as multiple students
have been rumored to know about it
including Gryffindor Lee Jordan Fred and
George Weasley also claimed to have
found this particular tunnel within
their very first week as students at
Hogwarts as described in the following
passage from the Philosopher's Stone
anyway we've got to go Lee Jordan
reckons he's found a new secret
passageway out of the school but it's
that one behind the statue of Gregory
the smarmy that we found in our first
week see you 5. the passage within the
West well there is a water well located
on the ground floor of the Castle's West
Tower which also acts as a secret
passage which leads once again into
hogsmeade the shaft of the well goes all
the way to a fountain in the village
connecting the two locations of course
this passageway is completely submerged
in water making it one of the more
difficult tunnels to use 6. the
passageway by hieroglyphic Hall in the
basement floor of Hogwarts is an area
called hieroglyphic Hall while we don't
know much about this Hall we do know
that it's present on the magical
Marauders map which also shows there's
little-known passage right off the
corridor 7. the stairway behind a
tapestry there's a hidden stairwell
connecting the ground floor to the
second floor behind a tapestry but
despite how little detail we have about
it apparently most Hogwarts students
know about its existence it's also
common knowledge that the stairway
features a trick step halfway up the
steps 8. the shortcut between the trophy
rum and charms classroom yet another
tapestry hides a different type of
Passage this time a magical shortcut
between the room that keeps the school's
trophies and the charms classroom two
locations which are indeed very far
apart in the Philosopher's Stone we see
Harry experience this shortcut first
hand they ripped through a tapestry and
found themselves in a hidden passageway
hurtled along it and came out near their
charms classroom which they knew was
miles from the trophy room
9. the shortcut between the first and
third floor another secret passage that
we don't have all that much detail about
this shortcut is known to be quite
spacious and connected the first and
third floor one can access it on the
first floor by going behind a statue the
exact one unknown and on the third floor
by finding precisely the right wooden
panels to open 10. the stairway between
the fourth floor and the fat ladies
Corridor concealed behind a bookshelf
there's a stairwell that connects the
corridor on the fourth floor of the
castle to the Hall of the fat lady on
the seventh floor in Gryffindor Tower
11. the magical passage between the
vanishing cabinets with one cabinet at
Hogwarts and the other in the shop organ
and Burke's in nocturnali the vanishing
cabinets have a magical link which can
transport you from one location to the
other undetected according to rumors the
original link had been operational until
1992 when peeves the Poltergeist
destroyed the Hogwarts cabinet Draco
Malfoy managed to fix this cabinet in
re-establishing the link and using it to
Ferry Death Eaters into the castle
undetected
12. the shortcut behind Timothy the
timid's portrait this painting of
Timothy the timid hides a shortcut
between the fifth floor hallway and the
herbology corridor like the majority of
secret passages hidden behind portraits
and paintings within the castle access
to this shortcut requires a password
which in this case happens to be flaming
earwigs 13. the shortcut behind a
Gifford Abbott portrait hiding a secret
passageway between the Castle's grand
staircase and the Transfiguration
Courtyard also known as the middle
Courtyard is one of the several
paintings of Gifford Abbott that hang up
on the Walls Within Hogwarts the
password to access the shortcut is
Dragon's egg
14. the passage behind a basil fronzak
portrait as a former Headmaster of
Hogwarts Professor basil franzak has
multiple portraits of himself hung
within the castle including the
headmaster's office one of the paintings
depicting him as a younger version of
himself hides a shortcut between the
grand staircase and the corridor and the
second floor close to the library to
gain access to this passageway one must
say studious success 15. the shortcut
behind damara dodderidge's portrait this
painting of damara daughterage is
located on the walls of the grand
staircase and hides a passage away from
the steps to the entrance of the
Castle's Clock Tower to use the shortcut
one must provide the password chops and
gravy 16. the passageway behind an
Edward rabnot portrait hiding a shortcut
between the corridor and the seventh
floor in the fourth floor hallway this
portrait is one of several of Edward
rabenot hung up at Hogwarts Edward's
portraits are known to have at least
three different different personalities
which likely accounts for the password
to his passageway being three heads are
better than one Seventeen the shortcut
behind a George Von ratica's portrait a
wizard astronomer George Von reticus has
several portraits within Hogwarts
including one which hides a passage
between the grand staircase and the
hallway on the seventh floor to get
access one must provide George with the
following password scurrilous scoundrel
18. the passageway behind a tamaritus
Shanks portrait one of the paintings of
the wizard tamaritus Shanks hides a
portrait between the school library and
the hall on the Castle's fourth floor
Corridor through interactions with Harry
Potter we learned that tamaritus enjoys
reading the papers which is probably why
his password is no news is good news 19.
the shortcut behind a Google stump
portrait Google's stamp was a shy wizard
whose portrait is not fond of being
around other paintings or people
unfortunately for him he has multiple
paintings of himself around the castle
one of which hides a secret passageway
between the viaduct entrance and the
corridor on the first floor the first
time Google's portrait shared his
password of Volo futuras unas was with
Harry Potter
20. the passage behind Percival Pratt's
portrait a shortcut is hidden behind the
painting of Percival Pratt which hangs
in the grand staircase and leads to the
school's Boathouse as a former poet
Percival can often be heard rhyming to
himself and passerbys making his
password of this password is absurd
quite amusing 21. the shortcut behind it
in Elizabeth Burke portrait this
portrait of Elizabeth Burke former
headmistress and pure blood supremacist
is not a particularly nice painting
hiding a shortcut between the entrance
to the Dungeons and a location near the
potions classroom there's little
surprise that the password to her
passageway is sotherins are Supreme
22. the passageway behind Boris the
bewildered portrait not much is known
about bars the bewildered other than the
fact that he has both a statue and a
portrait of himself in Hogwarts this is
rather iconic considering the fact that
his portrait hides a shortcut between
the corridors and the second and third
floor with the password of forget me
never and 23 magical exits from the room
of requirement within the room of
requirement Dumbledore's Army was
provided with an exit that would change
every day in order to keep their
meetings from being discovered the main
entrance to the room is located on the
seventh floor which we'll cover in just
a moment but it's unknown if the magical
Ways to Leave the chamber are always
there or if they only appear to meet the
needs of Dumbledore's Army the river
requirement also has a passageway that
leads directly to the portrait of Ariana
Dumbledore that hangs in the hog's head
In hogsmeade this passage only opens if
someone within the room of requirement
is hungry and has a need of food hidden
rooms Chambers and areas in addition to
all of the secret passageways and
shortcuts hidden throughout the castle
there are of course also plenty of
mysterious rooms and areas that are
unknown to the majority of Hogwarts
students and professors alike
fortunately for us Aaron is friends were
rather Adept at at uncovering these
places meaning that we know about
several of them such as 1. the room of
requirement although the room of
requirement is impossible and cannot be
found on any map including the Marauders
map it is known to be located in the
left hallway on the seventh floor of the
castle the hidden entrance can be found
across the corridor from the tapestry
depicting Barnabas the balmy trying to
teach trolls the ballet in order to
enter the room one only needs to stand
outside of it and think about what they
need a door appears and the room
provides a space that is exactly
whatever you need at that time 2. the
Chamber of Secrets with an entire novel
in the Harry Potter series named after
it the Chamber of Secrets is well not so
secret but although the rumor of its
existence was widely known very few had
the knowledge of where the entrance to
the chamber was or how to open it of
course that all changed in Harry's
second year at Hogwarts he discovered
that the Chamber of Secrets could be
accessed by speaking parcel tongue in
the bathroom in which Moaning Myrtle
resides which opened up a secret
passageway down to the entrance of the
chamber Under The Dungeons of the castle
at once the tap glowed with the
brilliant white light began to spin next
second the sink began to move the sink
in fact sank right out of sight leaving
a large pipe exposed a pipe wide enough
for a man to slide into within the
chamber-lived a basilisk which had been
placed there by Hogwarts founding member
Salazar Southern in the hopes that it
would one day Purge the school of
students not of pure blood it was said
that only the heir of Slytherin could
open the Chamber of Secrets as prior to
Harry only descendants of Southern had
the ability to speak parcel tongue and
this was the language required to unlock
the entrance
3. the room with the quill of acceptance
and book of admittance ever wonder how
students are selected for admittance
into Hogwarts while you may have assumed
that this was the decision of the school
said master or headmistress evidently
the choices are made entirely by an
enchanted quill and book known as the
quill of acceptance and book of
admittance these two magical items are
kept in a secret small locked Tower
close to the headmaster's office 4. the
Hufflepuff hidden Suites room the
founding member of Hogwarts Helga
Hufflepuff was known for her love of
good food so it should come as no
surprise that the Hufflepuff common room
is a few secret spaces dedicated to
Refreshments it's said that there's a
bookcase in the common room that is
actually a hidden door hiding a secret
room full of sweets 5. the room under
the viaduct Courtyard Bridge underneath
the bridge in the viaduct Courtyard
there's a secret room that can only be
accessed by solving a puzzle close to
the Castle's Central Hall
one must find the bridge with braziers
light them and complete the puzzle in
order to open the entrance to the room
6. the secret werewolf tapestry room
this room is accessible by a door shaped
like a shield with a k on it that's
imprinted on a tapestry hung within the
Castle's tapestry Gallery it is home to
a werewolf statue and several tapestries
depicting a story of a witch who was
once bitten by a werewolf 7. the
Hogwarts kitchen while not a secret per
se the Hogwarts kitchen is actually
quite hidden from students and
professors alike located below the Great
Hall one can only gain access to the
magical kitchen by finding a painting of
a bowl of fruit that's located in one of
the Castle's underground corridors and
tickling the pear in the bowl once
tickled the pair transforms into a door
handle allowing the witch or wizard to
enter
each and every classroom while certainly
not a secret finding the location of
each and every classroom within Hogwarts
is not necessarily easy with seven core
subjects and several other electives
there are more than a few classrooms for
students to memorize within the castle
they are one the Transfiguration
classrooms Transfiguration may be only
one subject but there are actually many
classrooms within the school dedicated
to this particular area of study
including class 1 and the Castle's first
floor class 34 on the third floor class
99 in the South Tower and classroom 1B
on the ground floor classroom 1B is near
the middle Courtyard and is quite large
with many high windows 2. The Charmed
classroom designated formally as
classroom 2E the charms classroom is on
the third floor of the school in the
hallway known as the charms Corridor
three the potions classroom one of the
most well-known classrooms within the
series the potions classroom is located
in one of Hogwarts dungeon areas and is
said to be quite cold during the winter
months 4. the history of magic classroom
this classroom is also known officially
as classroom 4f it can be found on the
first floor of the castle
5. defense against the dark arts
classrooms similar to Transfiguration
defense against the dark arts has
multiple classrooms in which this
particular subject is taught the two
classrooms for defense against the dark
arts are located on the first floor in
the North Towers class 104 and on the
third floor in classroom 3C 6. the
astronomy Tower astronomy classes were
conducted on the highest level of the
astronomy Tower which happens to be the
tallest tower in the castle this
location is used so that students May
observe the night sky unobstructed 7.
the herbology classroom Hogwarts
Greenhouse 3 is home to the herbology
classroom this area is used to teach
second years and older as it contains
some dangerous plants at first-year
students do not have the skills to
handle
8. the arithmetic classroom as an
elective subject offered to third year
students arithmancy is held in classroom
7A on the seventh floor of the castle
9. the Muggle studies classroom yet
another elective muggle Studies classes
are talked in a classroom on the
school's first floor the room can be
accessed through a showroom that has
muggle items and artifacts on display
10. the Divination classroom the
classroom for the study of divination is
located in the North Tower of the castle
the entrance to the room is through a
circular trap door at the top of the
Divination stairwell 11. the study of
ancient ruins classroom the study of
ancient runes often referred to as
simply ancient runes is held in
classroom 6A on the sixth floor of the
castle 12. the Alchemy rooms taught only
in years in which enough students
expressed interest it's likely that the
subject of alchemy is offered in the two
Alchemy rooms on the fourth floor of the
castle and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss any secret rooms passageways
shortcuts or Chambers please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forgets to
live